字幕: Yuriya Nakagawa
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんは自分の人生を変えたいと
思ったことがありませんでしょうか
大丈夫 変な宗教のセミナーではありません
（笑）
ご安心ください
僕はこの数年間で自分の人生が激変した
そんな１人なんです
なぜならば僕は本来ベンチャー投資家
という仕事をしているんですが
今日は全く関係のないですね
マラソンジャンキーというタイトルで
今日はここに立ってるんです
僕はこの数年間で
様々なマラソン大会を走ってきました
2012年の4月には
北極圏の周りをぐるぐる走る
フルマラソンを走ってきました
ちゃんと証拠も残っています —
GPSの記録です （笑）
その半年後には
今度は南極大陸に行きまして
100キロ走ってまいりました
さらにその５か月後には
南米のチリ・アタカマ砂漠に行きまして
250キロ — これは３名で一緒に
250キロ走るというチーム戦で
日本人で初めて
世界一になることができたんです
その結果 2013年に僕は
「マラソン中毒者」という本を出すことになり
それ以来僕は マラソンジャンキーなんです
なんですが 僕がこの本を出す３年半前は
こんな人間だったんです
今から20キロ太っていた
ただのデブのおっさんだったんです
（笑）
でも皆さんこう思うんですね —
「とはいえ小野さんは
昔から運動得意だったんですよね —
やってたんですよね」と
残念ながら これが10歳の僕の現実です
（笑）
体育の成績表
運動の技能の上中下の
下に丸がついてるんです
とにかく 運動が根っから大っ嫌いで
それ以来35年間 僕は
「運動なんかしたくない」—
そんな人生だったんです
そんな僕がですね
今では何かの病気の人間のように
こんな風になってしまって
なぜこのたった数年間の間で
こんな激変が起きたのか
皆さんこの激変の裏ワザ
知りたくありませんか
知りたくありませんか？
ありがとうございます
この裏ワザを １つご紹介しましょう
「ノータイムポチリ」
なんじゃらほい と（笑）
これはですね
自分の心の針が少しでも面白いものを見つけた
その瞬間にノータイムに
「ポチ」っと具体的な何かアクションする —
たったそれだけのことなんです
2009年の8月
さすがにデブりすぎた —
ダイエットしなきゃ と僕はですね
いやいやながらジョギングを
始めてみたんです
人間誰しもやってみて
初めて気が付くことがあるんですが
僕もそうだったんですね
あれ 俺 運動嫌いなはずなのに
ジョギングちょっと合うかも
俺ドＭだし 楽しいな
と気が付いちゃったんですね
（笑）
この楽しくなった瞬間
僕はノータイムポチリを行いました
ネットで見つけた３か月後の
フルマラソンの大会を見つけて
ポチッと 気軽にエントリーしたんです
これがノータイムポチリです
（笑）
面白いもので
人間は明確な目標が生まれると
マインドセットが変わるんです
それまで３か月後のフルマラソンなんて
無理だろと思っていた僕が
ポチッたことによって目標になって
どうやれば完走できるか？
ただ痩せたかった僕が
どうすれば完走できる自分に変われるか？
少し人生が変わり始めた —
これがノータイムポチリだったんです
これが初めて僕が
フルマラソンを走った時の写真です
なんだか今よりも
おっさんに見えてしまうんですけども
当然苦しかったんですね
でも完走するとめちゃくちゃうれしい
そして次に新しい感情が芽生えました
「ひょっとしたら
俺 もっとやれるんじゃないか？
もっとやりたい！」と
そこから僕は 次々新しい大会を見つけては
ノータイムポチリをしてしまう —
そんな風になっちゃったんです
その結果１年弱で100キロ走ったり
２年弱で 砂漠に250キロ
走りに行っちゃったわけです
そろそろ皆さんこう思うんですね
「いや 面白いモノ見つけたからと言って
そんなに普通ポチッたり
やっちゃったりしないんじゃないんですか —
できないんじゃないですか」と
考えてみてください
かつて皆さんにももっと今よりも
可愛くて純真だった時代が
かつてあったはずです（笑）
その時はこんな風に思っていたはずです
自由にですね 自分がなりたいもの
やりたいことっていうのを
思い浮かべていたんです
でも人間というのは経験を積むと
自分の中でできること できないことを
勝手に頭で決めつけて
自分の可能性を狭めてしまうんです
でも僕らは何歳になったって
やりたいことをみつけて
チャレンジを本来できるはずなんです
そんな時に便利なのが
このノータイムポチリなんです（笑）
なぜならばできるできない —
四の五の考える前に
「面白い」と思った瞬間に
ポチッと具体的なアクションをする —
たったこれだけのことなんですが
実は大きな変化を生む —
そうなんです
でも皆さん思うんですね —
「お前バカか」と（笑）
「まあポチッて
少しは人生変わるかもしれないけども
さすがに南極北極行かねえだろ 普通」と
確かにそうなんです
でもですね 僕は実は
ノータイムポチリを繰り返す中で
もう１つ ノータイムポチリとは別な
とある裏技を編み出していたんです
それを今日皆さんにお見せします
順番に見ていきましょう
これは５年前に 僕が
ツイッターでつぶやいた時の投稿です
砂漠マラソンというものが
世の中にあるというのを初めて知って
わくわくして
いつか出てみたい！と思って
とりあえずツイッターでつぶやきだけ —
宣言だけしたんですね
読んでみましょう
「30代中にサハラマラソンを
目指してみると宣言してみるテスト」
まあなんと超及び腰なんでしょう（笑）
残念ながら 大会のエントリーボタンまでは
ポチれなかったんです
ツイッターのつぶやきボタンは
ポチれたんです
でもいいんです
このつぶやきが僕の人生を
結果的に激変させたんです
このつぶやきを見たとある新井君 —
この会場にいるんですが
新井君という若者が
僕の目の前に現れてこう言ったんですね
「小野さん 僕も小野さんと
同じようなマラソン歴しかないんですけども
来年 砂漠マラソン 出ちゃうんですよ」
なんだって！なんだと！
その結果ですね
僕の中で「将来いつか…」
ぐらいに思っていた砂漠マラソンが
実は 俺も 来年
出れちゃうんじゃないか？と
一気に心の針がデーンと動いたんですね
こっから先は
もうノータイムポチリの出番です
もうこれ知った 49分後にはですね
もう翌年のゴビ砂漠マラソン
エントリーなう！ポチッ！
ポチるのは簡単なんです
なんなら勢い余ってですね
さらにはもう６分後
もう一つの砂漠マラソンまで
ポチ（笑）
やっちゃったんですねえ
アホですねえ（笑）
なんでこんなに
おっきな話になっちゃったんでしょうか
実はこの行動の中に
もう１つノータイムポチリとは
別な裏技を僕は
知らず知らずのうちに
編み出していたんです
それはなにか？
「自分まる見せ劇場化」なんです
なんじゃらほい
これはですね
僕の目標だとか夢だとか妄想だとか
もしくはそれに対する悩みだとか
ツイッター、フェイスブック上で
ばんばんばんばん まる見せしてたんです
まるで僕がステージに立って
ツイッター、フェイスブックの見てる人が
全部観客のように 勝手にまる見せしてたんです
それによって僕が思いもよらないような人との
出会いがあり
結果的にその出会いによって僕は
目標を大きく増幅することができたんです
確かに最初のノータイムポチリだけでも
僕の人生は少し変わり始めていました
でもその後ここまで —
北極ですとか南極ですとか
大幅に目標が増幅したのは
僕がまる見せすることによって
思いもよらない出会いを見つけて
その結果生まれた未来だったんです
これは僕が
南極100キロマラソンを完走した時の
フェイスブックの投稿です
完全に観客を意識して
ステージ衣装まで着ちゃってますね（笑）
この時は結果的に
２位という結果だったんですが
この投稿に対して
実にたくさんのコメントがあります
中には「２位、世界２位…
次の目標はなんだ？」
１位への期待が感じられますね —
観客の期待ですね
なんならこのストーリー
ブログ面白いけれども
本にする予定はないか？と
実はこういった僕のまる見せによって
自分の次なる目標を
勝手に僕は呼び込んでいたんです
これはなんの話をしているのかというと
まさに 今回のTEDxUTokyoのテーマでもある
「縁」の話なんです
自分をまる見せすることによって
自分を変えてくれるような人との縁を
僕が勝手に呼び込んでいたんです
皆さんでも信じられないかもしれませんが
こんなにべらべら喋っている僕 —
実は小さい頃は
コミュニケーション障害の人間だったんです
これは国語の成績 —
話すという技能 上中下の
下に丸がついています （笑）
本当なんです
僕はあまりにも話せなくて小学校時代
登校拒否を起こして入院していました
本当なんです
高校までずっと喋り下手でした
でもようやくこういう風に
喋れるようになるまでには
中学校高校と
いい出会いがあり　縁があり
少しずつ時間をかけて
ここまで喋れるように変わっていったんです
でもすごく長い時間が 正直かかりました
でも皆さん
今はインターネットの時代なんです
ソーシャルメディアがあるんです
自分をまる見せすることによって
自分を劇的に変えるかもしれない —
そんな縁をですね
急速に 世界の裏側にだって
広げていくことができる
そういう時代なんです
たった３年半ほどで ただのデブだった
インドアだった人間が
世界一になることができたり
そのストーリーが本にまでなっちゃったり
こんな思いもよらぬ未来が生まれたのは
まさに僕が自分をまる見せに
していたからだったんです
でも皆さん
ノータイムポチリして自分をまる見せする
非常にチャレンジ —
ハードルが上がるんですね
そうするとたまには怖くなって
僕も逃げたくなったりします
途中で泣きたくなったりやめたくなったり
そんな経験 たくさんあります
そんな時に
なんで僕は頑張ってこられたのか？
実はここにもですねもう１つ
この自分まる見せ劇場化の効果があったんです
僕は2013年のゴールデンウィークに
東京から新潟まで520キロ走るという
とても頭のよろしくないレースに出てきました
（笑）
まあほとんど寝れないで走るんですね
まずスタート地点のツイッターのつぶやきです
もう観客意識してますね —
「ちょっくら新潟いってきまふ」と
残念ながら全然拍手は起こっていません
リツイートもリプライも
何も生まれていません
これは331キロ地点 —
あまりにも眠くて寒くて疲れて
目の前にあったラブホテルに
思わず独りで駆け込んで
仮眠をとって目覚めたときの
ツイッターの投稿なんです
本当に死にたくなるくらい辛かったので
誰かに助けてほしいと —
みんなに面白いところを見せて
観客から応援をもらいたいと思って
必死に —
あんまり記憶に残っていないんですが
必死にやったんですね
目の前にあったカラオケのマイクを取って
鏡に映る自分をパシャリと撮って
ツイッターにあげたんですね
でもですね 少しずつ ぱらぱらとですけど
拍手が起こってますね
４リツイートですとか リプライ
でもこれによって少しの拍手が
やっぱり死にそうになっている —
「もうやめたい…」っていう僕を
少し勇気づけてくれるんですね
もう１つ ここで面白い事象が起きています
みんなに面白い姿を見せたい
という風に考えている自分は
実は自分を客観視しているんですね
まさに鏡に映っている自分を見ているように
自分を客観視することによって
「なに俺こんなバカなこと
面白いことやってんだろ」と
超絶苦しい状況にあるはずなのに
何か少しだけ
楽しい状況に変えることができるんです
これが自分まる見せ劇場化の効果だったんです
結果的に僕はふらふらになりながらも
520キロ完走することができ
その投稿をすることで
またさらにたくさんの拍手をもらうことができ
また次のチャレンジに続いていったわけです
でももちろんですね
うまくいく時ばっかりじゃないです
失敗するときだってあるんです
ジャングルマラソン
250キロ走りに行ったときは
５日目でリタイアしてしまいました
正直すごい悔しくて恥ずかしくて
悲しかったんです
でもいいんです —
これもまる見せしたんです
でも結果的にはこのまる見せによって
今までにないぐらいのたくさんの
応援、拍手、「感動した」というコメントを
もらえたんです
それによって僕は「なんだ失敗は怖いもの
じゃなくて見せびらかしていいものなんだ」と
もっと次につながるチャレンジの
エネルギーにすればいいんだという
当たり前のことを学ぶことができたんです
このように自分まる見せ劇場化は
場合によっては誰も見てなかったとしても
自分を 観客席をイメージして
友達だとか家族が見てくれるかもしれない
何ならもう死んでるかもしれない
じいちゃんばあちゃんに
天国から降りてきてもらって
観客席に座らせて
もしくは
将来こんな風になりたいと思っていた —
自分を夢見ていた過去の自分を
勝手に座らせることによって
「見られている！」
そしたら頑張らなきゃっていう
気持ちになるんですね
これがまる見せの効果です
もしくは
観客席からの自分を客観視することによって
「なにやってんのよ俺
もっと頑張れるだろ」と
「面白いことやってるんじゃないか」と
苦しい状況を
楽しく変えることができるんです
まあこんな話をしてもですね —
「そんな風に変われるのは
小野さんだけじゃないんですか？」
って皆さん思ってるはずなんですね
でも僕の周りには
同じようにして変わっていった人が
たくさんいるんです
今日は時間の関係で
１人だけご紹介したいと思います
これは僕の親友の山本良太くんです
彼はもともと日本の大手の半導体メーカーの
サラリーマンでした
まあ彼は非常に残念な人間でして
何が残念か[というと]
常に愚痴ばっかり ツイッター、フェイスブックで
つぶやいてるんですね
「日本のメーカーなんかいたってクソだ！」
「海外に出なきゃいけないんだ！」言いながら
「じゃあお前行けばいいじゃんか」と
「いやあ、俺はいいんだよ」
よくありがちなパターンです（笑）
何もチャレンジしない —
この残念な彼が
とあるノータイムポチリをきっかけに
未来が劇的に変わったんです
何をポチッちゃったか
なんと 僕と一緒に
サハラ砂漠250キロ走りに行くって （笑）
しかも大会の３か月前です —
酔っぱらっていたそうですね（笑）
思わず酔っ払っちゃってポチッと
エントリーしちゃったそうなんです
でも僕と同じように
ポチッちゃったことによって目標化されて
「やらなきゃ」と思って
しかも彼はまる見せもやってたんですね
「ポチッちゃったよ」
「エントリーしちゃったよ」ってことだとか
「でも大会近づいてきてなんか怖くなってきた…」
っていうこと全て
まる見せにしていったんです
結果これによって彼はたくさんの人の
共感を呼んで —
感動を呼んで声援を呼んで
非常に３か月頑張った
その結 果見事完走することができたんです
でも彼の激変は
ここからがスタートだったんです
それまで散々海外に行かなきゃだめだと
言っていた彼 —
でも動かなかった その彼がなんと
中国語もろくに喋れないのに
今では上海で働いているんです
しかも彼はもっと変わりました
それまでめちゃくちゃ
ネガティブなことばっかりしか喋れなかった —
ツイッターで投稿しかしていなかった彼が
非常にポジティブで
周りの人を勇気づけるような
投稿をする人間に変わったんです
これ見てみるとですね
いろんなことが書いてあるんですが
今までいろんなチャレンジをしてきた と
でも大事なことはですね
「人は思っているよりもできるもんなんです」
「考えるだけでは足りない
行動することが大切」
まさにこれノータイムポチリですね
こうも言っているんです
「僕は人がどれだけ
できるようになるのかを示していきます
そうすると
未来がちょっと面白くなるでしょ？」
まさにこれは自分を
まる見せしていくことによって
自分が変わっていく —
そんなことを言っているんです
こんな風にですね
僕も含め 彼も含め 皆さん全員このように
ちょっとした簡単なきっかけで
変わっていくことができるんです
自分を劇的に変えるかもしれない
そんなきっかけっていうのは
実は ごろごろあるのかもしれません
その中で 心の針が少しでも動いた瞬間
そのきっかけを逃さないように
ノータイムポチリで
具体的な一歩にしていく
たったこれだけのことが
とても重要なんです
そしてその姿をどんどん
まる見せしていくことによって
自分が思いもよらない縁を呼び込み
新しい未来を生んでいく
そんなことが誰でもできるんです
インターネットでポチるのは簡単です
今の時代だからできることなんです
今日この後 この会場の中から
新しいポチり —
新しい自分まる見せによって
劇的に未来が変わっていく
そんな方が現れて
僕が今度は 観客席側に回って
見ることを楽しみにしています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）